the most engaging in growth content is
the stuff that you are afraid to share
the creative idea that you've got there
in your mind that like oh I could never
post that like that's the thing to post
and then that's the thing to post
consistently and that's what will draw
you in like your Humanity your
vulnerability your those stories other
things that will
make people love you and want to dive
deeper into your world this is where
people struggle it's like how do I be
the expert but then also show that I
don't have all the answers and I'm still
afraid
a lot of people like if you look on
Instagram it's just that everybody looks
perfect and The Branding is perfect and
the cars and everything is perfect when
you're too perfect people actually can't
connect to you they need to know that
you're human and in your humanness is
the permission for people to actually
listen to your advice you might have all
the best advice in the world but people
won't listen to your advice until they
know that you're like them
so the question today was from Chris who
said what do you believe should be our
area of laser focus for online
businesses for the balance of the year
in terms of Engagement and growth I
think the biggest thing there is just
actually posting the content that you're
afraid to post like sharing the story
the message that you've got that you're
afraid of being judged on and post
um this is actually really timely
because this morning in movement makers
Zen before anybody showed up Zen played
this song called patapata which is this
South African song
um the artist was known as the the mama
of Africa and and I love that song and
uh it's a Cha-Cha song that that I Nina
and I danced to a lot and Zayn didn't
know that I liked that song and so after
we got off movement makers that song
which is in my head in my head in my
head in my head in my head and so I
decided for some reason that I needed to
learn the lyrics of that song because I
kind of
hummed along you know when it's a song
in a different language you don't quite
know what they're saying so I said
and there's like one line in English and
that's the one that you always get
anyway so
I I then committed an hour today on a
day that I don't have an hour to learn
the lyrics of patapata
and I and I I started filming it on my
Instagram stories to ask for help like
does anybody speak this language does
anybody know because it sounds like some
of the syllables she's saying she's
she's skipping it she's not actually
seeing it so I'm stressed out like I'm
trying to figure out how do I get this
song out
and and now I'm I'm asking for help and
then I keep I keep at it keep at it slow
the song down to 50 percent
slowly going like syllable by syllable
until I finally feel like I got it so
then I share guys I think I got it I
think she's this this thi is silent
and then I keep practicing keep
practicing keep practicing and then I
get the full speed and I film it is like
here I am full speed and I'm rocking and
rocking out on the on my trampoline
singing patapatin you know this language
I don't understand and then I get so
animated that I hit my phone and it
falls down and that's the end of the
video and and I shared the whole thing
on my Instagram story
and like that's the type of content that
people don't often get to see that's the
kind of content that we're afraid to
post that's the kind of content that
we're afraid of being judged for it's
like I thought you're supposed to be
some business Guru what are you doing
spending an hour learning some song that
that's the thing that humanizes you
the question was about engagement and
growth like that's how you get engaged
in a growth is showing The Human Side Of
You the thing that if that was me five
years ago I would have been incredibly
embarrassed to share that I'm singing I
don't have a good voice singing voice so
I'm singing out loud to some language
that I don't know probably making
mistakes all over the place
dancing on my trampoline and smashing my
phone over right it's like the most
imperfect thing ever but that moment of
creativity and posted people are already
damning me with like reactions laughing
celebration party more than a typical
story would get more than just a guys
today you need to focus let me talk
about Focus for the day right so the
most engaging in growth content is the
stuff that you are afraid to share your
story creativity the the creative idea
that you've got there in your mind that
like oh I could never post that like
that's the thing to post and then that's
the thing to post consistently and
that's what will draw you in like your
Humanity your vulnerability your those
stories other things that will
make people love you and want to dive
deeper into your world it doesn't mean
this is where people struggle it's like
how do I show how do I be the expert but
then also show that I don't have all the
answers and I'm still afraid
a lot of people like if you look on
Instagram it's just that everybody looks
perfect and The Branding is perfect and
the cars and everything is perfect
when you're too perfect people actually
can't connect to you
they need to know that you're a human
and in your humanness is the the then
permission for people to actually listen
to your advice because people won't
listen you might have all the best
advice in the world but people won't
listen to your advice until they know
that you're like them
and so that's the content that we're the
most afraid to share because we don't
want to go back to being that person
we're embarrassed by this stuff about
ourselves
but in sharing that is the thing that
opens up the world to you to get that
growth and engagement so back to the
question of what's the most engagement
content for the for the rest of the year
that's what I would focus on the stuff
that you're afraid to post sharing your
story taking me deep inside your
insecurities vulnerabilities show me you
doing the things that you do that make
you human that people really connect
with that's my thought of the day with
your questions now obviously turn it
over to you guys so you put your hand up
try to get to as many as I can Niles
already got his hand ready to go what do
you got man thanks this is awesome and I
love that this is uh that's so that's
something I've been struggling with I'll
be honest with you but at the same time
and so I'm going to ask a technical
question I asked you this in the past
somewhere else but when it comes to the
actual tracks that you use because I my
background I love to dance dance fitness
is actually my background and now I'm
moving somewhat away from it but I love
it and I still want to show that playful
side and that was a big part of my life
so I want to be able to show that again
technical side was the actual uh I love
that you're dancing there
um the idea is um uh technical side how
long is a track allowed did you use the
real track or did you get an edit of
that actual song because I love that
song too but I'm not that I'll use it I
want to get an idea of what what will
actually put a red band against me
yeah yeah great question and Nile
if it becomes your business then you you
start doing the research in the work
some tracks some companies care a lot
some companies care zero for me because
I'm not in the music like music is not
my my game
um I just recorded it on Instagram it
was a IG live story and and those don't
get typically picked up or banned or
anything
um if I were to turn it into a YouTube
video it might I don't know patapata is
a pretty obscure
song that most people don't really know
about but if you did if you pulled the
Taylor Swift song it's probably gonna
get
blocked or demonetized right those are
the two options either block it or they
demonetize it so at the beginning though
don't let that stifle the creativity
I made the I was feeling that song
Because Zane put it in my head so now I
have to dedicate an hour to figure out
the lyrics to this song and and I was
frustrated and I slow it down and I
speed it up and then I finally get it
and you get to see how happy I am that I
knock over the phone and it's just so
exciting and that will live fine on
Instagram and even if it just disappears
in 24 hours and I don't do anything else
with it awesome if I download it and
turn into a YouTube video maybe that
gets blocked and it doesn't see the
light of day but if I'm going to keep
doing it then I'd have to pick songs
that are going to get through
and that becomes the business to know
which songs get through but at the
beginning don't let those questions
stifle the creative output because if I
spent that time thinking I wonder if
this song is going to get blocked I
wonder if this is gonna then I don't
make the song and then that moment is
gone right right so we just start
overthinking right away from the
beginning instead of just creating and
yes you'll make some mistakes I mean I
didn't think I didn't mic myself up I
didn't set up a cat like the camera when
I'm doing the full shot I'm only on like
the bottom half because I don't have the
the stand to make it happen right
overthinking all that stuff then leads
to the creativity going away and then
nothing gets created
instead of this magical moment that was
created right so it's gonna be your
business you have to know it otherwise
go create go make you'll learn as you go
yeah thanks Evan appreciate it cool uh
iPhone has her hand raised welcome
iPhone
this is the first time I have uh the
courage to to show my face now she's
doing it ladies and gentlemen
good job I love it I love salsa I'm in
Vancouver Canada I danced every weekend
on the beach nice yes salsa on the beach
is hard
yeah we we have a concrete like oh okay
okay good because salsa and sand is you
can't turn for anything so that's good I
love it yes yes I'm following you on the
salsa scene as well but uh um my name is
Olivia I've been hiding but now I'm
coming out but there's an opportunity to
partner with uh with company I'm doing
it tonight my dream is to do interesting
training and I know that my purpose is
the language this company's purpose they
have a lot of size like presence
Christian Missionary Training healthcare
workers but not nursing projects I'm
expanding their Market to China but
we've been talking for a few months and
they're not paying me anything and then
now they give me a I I asked for then
the man last like don't sign a
non-disclosure agreement they want me to
work exclusive with them without a pay
structure or a partnership contract but
it is my passion and I've been trying to
take off for over 10 years and I
couldn't by myself should I just like
keep on serving them and giving them for
free or should I say like a draw a line
understand say you know you pay me as a
consultant or an employee or let's draft
up a contract so first off
I wouldn't sign an NDA that prevents you
from working with other companies
because you your passion I would split
this up like your passion is to be in
this space
your passion isn't to be with this one
company
there's lots of companies who you could
do this thing with
your passion is being the space so
anything that prevents you from being in
this space
that locks you into one company
especially unpaid I'm not a fan of if
you look at what I do with with YouTube
stuff I've seen
everybody's channels
I don't I don't sign ndas for anybody
when I was in a venture capital business
I saw so many deals of different
businesses we never signed an NDA
because it becomes your reputation
if you screw one person over or you
share details of somebody that
damages your entire reputation like if
Zane the man built to serve coach if
he's out sharing oh you know what Olivia
said to me in our private session last
week it's like then then it's over like
his entire reputation as a coach is gone
you have to keep
information confidential that becomes
your reputation
um so definitely taking anything out
that's exclusivity
I like the idea of doing free work at
the beginning
if if people don't recognize your value
the thing with free work is you have to
do free work with ideal clients
so at the beginning you're doing the
free work you're building up a
reputation you're getting to you prove
yourself but is this an ideal client who
can ultimately pay you and they might be
doing the ideal work that you want to
get into but they may not be the ideal
client for you you're already shaking
your head so yeah they were like we
don't have any funding and I was like
well let's draft a like uh like you know
we split the cost and the you know the
revenue they're like but we don't know
what's how much how many students you
can get and market and so there's
nothings that yeah go ahead
so you want to be in the space and doing
free work is great to start but they
have to be with ideal clients so if it's
not this client
then it's finding more people now you
have something to show now now you've
done it I mean it's great don't don't
feel like you made this terrible
decision now you've got some experience
in the field that you can point to now
you've built some extra contacts and
connections now you've built some
momentum and you've also shown to
yourself that you really do like this
when you're just looking at it you don't
know if you actually love it but now
you're in it's like I actually do love
this thing now it's a matter of finding
more companies to work with not being
tied down to this one client that
doesn't like it's not even the it's not
having funding is one thing but also not
being willing to work something out it's
a mindset shift too right yeah but it's
just that's not who those are not the
ideal clients that you want to be
chasing down so if I'm going to be
looking at okay who are
10 other companies that are trying to do
the same thing and how can I go and yes
prove myself at the beginning even if
it's free work but that I provide so
much value that I want to work with them
um even using xan as an example he he
joined my YouTube gaming live streams uh
where we play League of Legends and
answer questions and he he brought so
much value that then I'm looking for
like how do I help Zan out more like how
do I love this guy I love collecting
good people how do we do something
together so the starting point was
connecting with other people I can't get
him to Jason's like hey you need to do
an IG live with Jason who's Jason don't
worry about it you're gonna love him
he's great you guys are kind of hungry
both have like the biggest Smiles in the
world the biggest hearts in the world
you'll love each other right so he's
like all right igdm's Jason and they do
their thing that then led to then you
know becoming the Builder serve coach
so that's that's doing free work and
building your reputation to the point
where opportunities happen but if if the
people in the company aren't giving you
opportunities
and they're just making you work for
free and sign non-disclosure and
exclusivity agreements it's just not the
right fit so now it's just branching out
find 10 other companies
who are doing similar things where you
can come and bring your value to help
them
and then work your path towards getting
paid for it
yeah there's a thing about Christian
there's a lot of volunteers serving it's
just not the business mentality and I
really want to combine the two but you
know it's hard to find in a space maybe
it's just my scarcity I thought oh
they're Christians you know values are
aligned you know so yeah but listen
there's a lot of people who will have
values aligned that just may not be a
Christian organization like there may be
a for-profit there's a lot of for-profit
companies run by Christians who have
strong values
right okay okay so those are the people
who you might want to search out instead
of always living in the non-profit world
I love non-profit I love free like what
are we doing here this is free you guys
bought
a book for 15 bucks or something or some
of you might have just pirated it
so this but but in order to do this in
order to do the free stuff you have to
also have an income stream to support
you and your organization and the more
you build up mini constream the more
your team can also contribute you know
Sandra my assistant is in here and she
sets all this stuff up for me so I can
afford to hire her to do this to allow
me to come here and do this right so
there's lots of organizations who are
who are making money who also like not
every company has a as a devil Soul
right they're living the the mission the
values but also
uh are making money and and would love
what you're bringing you just have to do
the work to go find those people
thank you so much you're amazing yeah
cool good luck and hey welcome welcome
thank you for turning on your camera for
the first time and asking a question
that's great that's what it's all about
thank you uh who's next Jose what do you
got uh so uh great to see you
um just want to ask a quick I have a
couple of questions but I'm gonna ask
more now and if there's more time and I
can come back to it great
um in the book when you talked about uh
when you uh you know uh left your first
company with your partner and then you
realize what were you gonna do you
decided to model you the success of the
Bill Gates and you talked about how you
uh focused on uh forming Partnerships
and alliances and I just wanted to get
maybe a little bit more feedback on that
like specifically I'm in the process of
starting a um a nationwide quick service
restaurant
um with a healthy uh approach and so
I've been uh I've been one one way that
I formed a partner in alliances was
bringing into a fold an old business
colleague who has over 20 years of
marketing experience
um and I partnered up with him to kind
of like you know help me in the form of
the company and and being Partners but
I'm trying to figure out
just a little bit more on that like if
you were starting a quick service
wrestling I guess I mean what might be
some of the Partnerships and alliances
that you might look to to form
so
what I meant in the book wasn't so much
bring a business partner into your
company because that's like getting
married so most business Partnerships
fail because people look at well they
have this skill set and I have this
skill set it's going to be perfect
Meanwhile your values are completely
different
and so you're in the dating phase hey
you have 50 I have 50 let's start this
company together but because the values
are a mismatched it really is like you
need to date before you get married so
I'd be I'd be it's not that Partnerships
can't work out just you need to treat it
like it's going to be a marriage you
might spend more time during the week
with them than your husband or wife
right I mean that just a reality of
starting the business so you better
really like them
um so it doesn't mean don't make that
partnership but I would test something
small work on one thing together before
you go and do some big thing together
like what's the first step that you guys
can take together
um there's a guy who emailed me to say
hey I want to help you with your email
marketing okay great write me write me
one email
and see what it looks like and I liked
it so then I hired him to do 10 emails
okay great so now we're going to see
what he comes up with with for his 10
emails and if maybe I the more people
hang around me the more I just start
businesses with them
right it's like this is what I love to
do we Zane now has a business together
Drew has a business together like Alex
all these people like the more time we
spend together tomorrow I'm looking for
opportunities and we just it just
gravitates towards doing some kind of
company together but it always starts
with something small at the beginning
okay so that's what I would do with him
or her like something small at the
beginning to make sure that you work
well together well he and I like I said
we've had a long time relationship for
about 15 years and we've worked together
um and and so yeah I'm figuring that out
and I definitely value that feedback but
in terms of like the the company itself
like what how would I go about then
let's say procurement types of
Partnerships and Alliance that would be
correct for the brand that don't involve
equity and partnership yeah so you're
looking at how do I start for me if it
were me how do I start this business
spending the least amount of money
possible restaurants are are the worst
it's like it's the number one failure
business in America
and especially now right so I'll be
looking I'd look into what Mr Beast is
doing
ghost kitchens
that's exactly what we're doing yeah I
mean that's that makes a ton of sense
find people who restaurants are
struggling right now you find the
companies who can make your product
whatever you're selling whose ethics and
values kind of fit with what you're
doing and find a way to connect
you don't have to worry about going like
Nationwide yet but you start what city
are you in I'm in Philly and I'm looking
to open either in Philly uh and or Miami
yeah but like do Philly you're in Philly
don't worry about Miami how you gonna do
Miami you got a flat you got to be in
Miami like you got to make it happen
Philly's a big enough market definitely
you're not in some tiny little rural
middle nowhere right so you're in Philly
so you start you want to actually go and
meet restaurant owners and Pitch them
the idea and the model's already been
proven
people are already doing this and
restaurants are struggling right now to
figure out a business opportunity and if
they can make some extra money without
having to do
you know a lot of extra work they're not
spending any time marketing they already
have the staff and the team and the
ingredients and everything else right
that's your best bet and then make prove
it in Philly
and then you might need five locations
in Philly
and then worry about Miami but I
probably go somewhere closer to Philly
just for your own sanity and traveling
and all that stuff
sure thank you so much make sense uh
how's our time lady Lexi quick what do
you got I was asking you something about
extension
uh and then ask you about that club and
you said no dot Club is for uh clubhouse
so
um are the only ones suitable the ones
you end with.com for General websites or
can we also use for instance dot life
dot com is just the the standard that's
what people
I would I would default to a.com if you
can or put your name just find some way
to get a.com like a DOT live so I use
Evan carmichael.live we have one if you
want to go to my live gaming channel
tonight 6 p.m Eastern you type in Evan
carmichael.live it'll forward to the
YouTube stream
the especially with DOT live and in
movement makers you asked about Club
dot Club the perception is it's a
clubhouse thing
dot live the perception is it's a live
thing so if you're going to be pointing
if it's lady lexi.live the perception is
you're going to lead me to a live stream
of some kind
it's going to go to your Instagram where
you're going live or a YouTube channel
where you're going live but if it's just
a website and you're not going live it's
just a disconnect
so I don't I don't I mean.com is ideal
if you're going to go dot net or dot us
or dot whatever it can all still work I
think honestly the website is becoming
less and less important
something
dot com is taken that that's what the
the thing is and I can't reach the owner
yeah so she just transfers it to her
Facebook page and I know there's also
the life with an f and since I always
talk about lady Lexi's live on the road
yeah lady Lexi something
lady Lexi whatever else.com uh and keep
you if it so if you really want to chase
it down you can I mean Brendan Bouchard
tells the story of it took him six years
I think to get brendan.com
where he just every three months emailed
the guy again like hey if you wanna if
you're ready to sell hey if you're ready
to sell hey if you're ready to sell the
guy who owns evan.com
is not using it it's it's forwards to
some hotel in Germany or or Russia or
something I don't know or maybe Holland
I don't know it just forwards to someone
they're not using it
right but I don't care enough about
evan.com and if Evan Carmichael was
taken I would I would have it believe
Carmichael it's like it almost doesn't
matter
more important is you creating the
content building your brand but I I
think the only thing you want to do is
not create confusion if you put a dot
club or dot live it creates confusion
true it was like the name I don't think
a company name really matters that much
like what did Evan Carmichael mean
before Evan Carmichael what is what did
Xerox mean like the guy who made Xerox
picked his name because he wanted a name
so difficult to pronounce that once you
got it you wouldn't forget it
like
x-e-r-o-x is crazy what kind of name is
that how do you pronounce that you look
at it on the sheet you have no idea what
that means but once you got it you don't
forget Jason Wells right everybody
messes up Jason nobody puts a y and
Jason right it's a weird spelling but in
his branding it's all about the why and
so you remember oh why because his his
purpose-driven brand helps you figure
out your your why and so his why you
know he made that work for him so Jason
Wells with the Y now is easy to know
that that's who it is versus any other
Jason out there so the brain is what you
make it you just don't want to have
when you attach yourself to something
that already has meaning
it means something
when you create something brand new you
can attach the meeting you want an
American you know election debates the
the presidents or the president to be
always has the pin of the U.S flag
because the U.S flag means something
so they're trying to attach themselves
to that symbol so when you're using
symbols or extensions that have meaning
you have to make sure you match the
meaning
otherwise you create a new symbol
you know the the airplane means
something to me I mean it might have
some kind of meaning but in general the
people don't really know what it means
I'm assigning meaning to it the name
Evan Carmichael I'm assigning meaning to
it so I I'm okay with anything pick
whatever you want I just don't want to
confuse people
um in the process because you're picking
a name that doesn't represent or like an
extension doesn't represent your actual
brand
okay cool thank you
from Laura how to start creating content
online to build a community
you've got this right I mean if you're
here you've got this
this is what you need to start looking
at the last section uh the thought
leadership section
that's your starting point right so I
want you to make content around your who
your why your how that's why I wrote it
here because
I want you to have the Tactical steps
for what to actually do next so it's
great you find your who your why your
how like okay I'm Purpose Driven I'm
Mission driven I know what I want to do
now but
what content do I make like what's my
next actual step right so looking at the
thought leadership content template
to try to master it it takes a while to
get
even if you're even if you've done
videos before it takes a while to get so
it's worth practicing but taking people
inside your story because ultimately
we're trying to help the people who
currently are who we used to be
right your mission is to help people who
are like you I was just doing an
interview and the guy said
um I love momentum I love momentum I'm
addicted to momentum that's what I
really love doing it's like okay you
love momentum but you know the greater
what you actually love
is not you just getting momentum you'll
love helping other people get momentum
you want to help other people get
momentum and then there's like silence
as he's the kind of absorbing it right
but that's ultimately like we want to
serve so whatever you want for I want to
spread belief to the world that's what I
really want
right I want to believe more in myself
and I want to spread belief to the world
um
there's another guy who came on and then
said well what if you love playing
violin
so go recognize that you don't actually
love playing violin
you don't love the instrument you love
the the feeling that it gives you like
you picked up the violin why because
it made you heal and made you get over
some trauma and made you a better person
like somehow playing the violin
helped you as a human
and so if you're going to help other
people maybe it's teaching them violin
maybe it's
um playing performing violin maybe it's
being a violin coach but it's not the
violin that matters the violin is just
the instrument
and it's actually an instrument but the
violin is just the tool
it's the emotion behind the tool you
want people to feel more X and violin is
the way to actually make it happen right
I want people to feel more belief
and I do it by sharing the videos
because that's what helped for me
learning from successful people
all those like Bill Gates in his story
that's what really saved me when I was
getting started
um so now I try to
give that back and also do things like
this and try to be here because this is
when my favorite thing to do when I'm
traveling is is to meet up with local
entrepreneurs and just have a coffee
shop jam session
so every time I'm traveling and I
haven't done it for a while now because
of covert but normally anytime I'm
traveling I try to book an extra day if
I can
to then have the next morning before I
fly out to have a coffee session and
I'll email anybody on my list and maybe
maybe somebody paid like a couple
thousand bucks to be in the main event
that I was speaking at but then anybody
can come to a coffee shop you know if
you're homeless we've got homeless
people show up you don't know they're
homeless but they're homeless they could
show up and not even buy anything and
and sit and still enjoy that's still my
favorite
thing to do because I I just like I like
seeing
the faces and I like seeing people win
right I want I want to spread belief to
people and so you know same thing uh for
you guys whatever you whatever your who
is you want to spread that to the world
you want other people to feel it too
um Zane wants more confidence for
himself and he wants more to have other
people feel confident and if a
conversation with Zan leads you to
having more confidence in yourself
that's going to make Zan come alive
she's like yes this is why I do this
because
uh Joey's asking how do you choose to
remove videos as you get better at
producing higher quality videos you
leave the old ones should we yeah yeah
yeah yeah I love leaving the old weather
I hate that people delete videos
I would never the only reason to delete
a video is if it doesn't represent your
beliefs anymore like you made it from a
really negative space and it's not who
you actually are not because of poor
production quality
because if you think about what your
what is your message
what's your message that you want to
share to the world so you know mine is
believe hopefully you've gone through
the exercise and you found yours
um
but is your message going to be don't do
anything until it's perfect
like never release anything unless it's
is that going to be the message that you
want people to feel is that the message
you want you would tell your kids or the
people around you no so
you don't live that right like you're
hiding all of the imperfect things so
then people only see the perfect
you're basically saying okay I only make
perfect stuff
where I I don't like looking back on my
first videos like oh my gosh
I mean I miss the hair but but besides
that you know it's so bad nervous and
memorizing and all that stuff and it
just it's it's cringe worthy looking
back on it at least for me but I like
that they're still there
that you can see where I came from
because I think that actually I could
say I'm introverted and shy and I was
afraid to be in front of the camera and
I and I struggled I can say that but you
can go back and watch it like don't
believe me go back
you could they're all there go back and
watch my first videos you see how bad
they were see how the camera was shaky
see how I didn't know what I was saying
like you can go back and see it and and
most people don't but some people do and
I think that ins that Journey becomes
the inspiration
um so as long as you're still proud of
the intent of that video
and that you did the best you could with
what you had at the time then I would
keep it up if you find that the intent
was was now wrong or something you're
not proud of I would still probably
leave it up anyway but I've always made
intentional videos you know I think it's
just if it was a reactionary video like
somebody said something on the news and
you got triggered and then you made some
video and
um now you're not proud of that video
but because the intent came from a
negative place instead of a positive one
maybe in that scenario but otherwise if
if the intent was positive
I would just I would keep it up and and
be proud that you that you made that
that you did that like as much as the
content of my old videos is a little
embarrassing to watch I'm still proud
that I did it
I don't even know how I did it because
I'm I'm shy and introverted and I
couldn't do it with my sister in the
room or just how did I do it I don't
know I just did it but I that's just a
reminder of the growth that kind of
we've come through
um
so yeah so as long as you're still proud
of the intent I would I would do it
uh
uh what else working on being perfect
might lead to never bringing a service
or uh service to product to the public
yeah I mean I think that's it 100
um and the last interview I was doing
somebody was asking what what's the most
common bit of advice that you see from
successful people and number one is
always love what you do like you have to
love what you do people just
think they're going to win doing work
that you hate you're going to give up so
you have to you have to do the work that
you love do you enjoy the process well I
do this like why am I here because I
love you guys and not even like you
individuals although I know some of you
and love you as humans like individuals
too but just this this this idea this
being here
um when Andrew said most authors don't
do it because they don't actually like
it it's just a strata it's a launch
strategy right and then they I just I
like it it's fun right
um
so that's and it's not like right or
wrong it's just when you're doing the
thing that you love you're gonna have a
better chance of winning
um but the other thing is starting like
starting starting you got to start you
got to make you got to create people are
asking what uh what platform should I be
on and what camera gear should I use and
in all the time you spent thinking about
those questions you could have already
made 10 videos it's like just get the
videos and you figure it out as you go
really I mean there is no perfect start
there is no perfect platform to be on
you have to create you have to make you
have to go
um
somebody asked me this on clubhouse it's
like you're you've been thinking about
starting a clubhouse room great
you thought about it so now you have to
do it
but I don't know what day and I don't
know who to invite and I don't know none
of that make your first just go open a
room if nobody shows up then you're
talking to yourself for for 10 minutes
and then you close it like your first
video needs to be that your first
reading needs to be hey it's Evan I
decided to make a video today because I
want people to believe in themselves
more and I don't know I've never done a
video before and I don't know what I'm
gonna talk about
um but I'm I'm I got a message and
yeah so first video done believe right
post next
right and the next one becomes a little
bit better
I think we're just overthinking way way
way way way too much
um that sounds like my first video it
says Belinda yeah
yeah I love it Belinda that's what I'm
talking about that's
that's your first video like if your
first video doesn't suck then you suck
because you waited too long then you
should have done it three years ago
right like your first video is supposed
to suck that's that's the point
um I know we're at time but one one more
question what do we got Trenton's asking
how do you start doing less like doing
the work slash tasks that actually
matters uh I really focus in on my
calendar so your calendar is your is
your daily actions right you can have
goals and dreams and Ambitions great
things you say you want to do but it's
really about
what are you taking action on so your
calendar really really matters next I
pay attention to energy zones so
today's a Thursday making this Thursday
I'm doing all day it's my extrovert hat
on so I start with movement makers
because that always gets me feeling
great and energy and love and Vibes and
then and then it's I did like three
shows before this in between and after
this I'm I'm going until nine o'clock at
night right so it's like straight
but I'm always in the energy zone of
just
spreading the message today is public
facing day spread the message
uh and then every other day I'll do like
yesterday was totally off
yesterday I wake up like what is my
project day what do I want to do today
totally open
because Tuesday was YouTube day banging
out crazy videos so on Tuesday I'm not
thinking about Readers Club
right and today I'm not thinking about
YouTube videos so already just not
having a distraction in my headspace
really helps and you may not be able to
plan your whole days but planning
whatever time you can control having a
plan for that really really matters to
stay in the energy Zone so if I'm making
one video I might as well make eight
because I'm already in the same Zone to
be able to make the eight
um
so that's kind of macro when you look at
your calendar and you see like hey do my
actions map to my ambitions then on the
inside of that is how much do I how
strategic do you want to be on each day
so on Thursdays do I do readers group do
I do uh you know movement makers do I do
this interview who do I say yes to who
do I say no to you know what helps for
me I'm probably not strategic enough I
go off a Vibe like I like this person I
want to do an interview with them
and I don't check how many followers
they have and how many episodes they've
done and I you know a lot of I could be
more strategic with that probably just
in terms of getting the results but
I just like people I like just like
picking people off a Vibe like I like
how they messaged me I like the words
they used you know like Lisa Nichols
saying I received that you know it's
just like they say something that sticks
with you it's like man I like this
person we can make some good content
together so I'm going to say yes to them
even though I have no idea who their
previous guests have been or numbers or
anything else but that's me that may not
be the right thing for you but but
that's what works super well for me
um but definitely Ambitions and then
having it in your calendar and then
constantly evaluating your calendar see
if it's helping you get to where you
need to go
welcome board guys good to have
everybody back uh today's topic was
interesting was giving yourself
permission to live out your purpose
um man it took me a long time to get
comfortable with being up front
uh with being being the guy being in
front
um I used to always feel like it was an
ego trip
that I didn't I didn't have to be famous
I had no need to be famous
um I fought with my agent for years on
it and
it wasn't until I really realized that
sharing my story was actually selfless
that people could see themselves in me
if they don't know your story they won't
listen to your advice you know you look
at Evan there the other Evan
not this time we got Evans back to back
but Evan looks like he's got it all
together he's all figured out he's got
this nice shirt on and the pictures
behind him and he looks like he's all
he's got it all figured out and if
imagine if the guy who you see in front
of you is making videos about how to get
out of alcohol addiction
you're like yeah but you don't
understand me dude look at you you've
got this fancy life you've got it all
figured out meanwhile he knows he knows
exactly what it's like and so until you
share your story I've been sharing his
story me sharing my story you guys
sharing your story it's not about you
it's not about people just praising you
for what you've come through it's about
other people being able to see
themselves in you that people won't
listen to me as much for getting out of
alcoholism because that I didn't
struggle with that that's not that
wasn't something that I had a challenge
with but Evan tinsman he did and so if
you didn't know that about him you
wouldn't want to listen to him I got
another guy telling me what to do he
doesn't get it
so that's why it's super important that
you share your story and and give
yourself permission to share the story
uh that that if you guys can pick that
up quickly that's amazing because that
literally took years for me to figure
out years of fighting years of pushing
by people close to me like my agent
who's like
just frustration on his part I'm sure to
slowly convince me and it wasn't until I
realized that hey sharing my story is
actually serving
and we go through it in in and build the
surface while there's sections on that
but
um yeah giving yourself the permission
to do it is super valuable and um
anyway I hope I hope that meant
something to you I hope that helped you
anyway the point of these sessions is
yes kind of lead with a quick thought
like that but but I want to be able to
help you guys out this we've turned it
into little mini live coaching sessions
whatever you're struggling with however
I can help
get your movement off the ground
um let's let's open it up what do you
guys what's what's going on how can I be
a value who wants to go first
I'll go first all right let's go first
so I know that when you first started
you did all the
promoting and content for your videos
that you know for your stuff at what
point did you hire somebody and now when
you hire somebody what exactly do you
have them to do like for if you if I
were to hire somebody to do my content
do they actually create the content not
the videos for the content and edit
that's my question
so the first person I ever hired in my
business this wasn't my business right
the first person I ever hired was to do
data entry for me because I hated data
entry and he was actually much better at
it than I was and so he took two hours
off of my table and he gifted that to me
and I paid him and it only took him an
hour because he was faster and better at
it than I was on the YouTube side of
things I the first hire was an editor
part-time and this really comes down to
like what do you want to be great at
so there's no right or wrong answer it's
the right or wrong answer for you I did
not want to be great at editing I like
actually at the very beginning the
things I like messing around with stuff
I like playing around I like seeing
the ins and outs of it and so I quickly
picked up Movie Maker which is probably
the most basic video editing
software that you can use so I picked
that up
um got used to it but then quickly
realized that I don't I don't like this
I'm not good at it and I don't like it I
wasn't good in front of the camera
either Belinda I mean if you watch my
videos I watched it back it's like I'm
not good at that either but
I like it you know I want to get better
at it I want to improve video editing I
didn't like it and I didn't want to get
better and I didn't want to improve so I
knew that that would always be a
limitation for me that I would I would
force myself to do it if I had to but as
soon as I could get that off my plate
then I would so the hiring a part-time
editor was my first hire and I think a
lot of you can you can you don't have to
hire full-time you don't have to just go
out and hire somebody full-time to help
you you can hire somebody part-time
Project work a couple hours a day or
even a couple hours a week depending on
what you're doing so it's really
figuring out what do you hate the most
that has to get done and then and then
working on that so for me it was editing
now when I hire it really just depends
on what what the Need Is Right we've got
30 something people on the team so
you know if I'm hiring somebody just to
be in charge of my LinkedIn content that
that may not be the best strategy for
you for where you're at right now
um but if anybody's trying to be in
front of the camera and that's where
your Genius is then editing becomes the
fastest one so it's editing part-time
Editor to then full-time Editor to then
he got kidnapped so I had to get another
editor that was a crazy story he just
disappeared for for three or four months
this guy was super reliable always on
time and then like just dropped off to
face on the map and then he came back
like three four months later and said
sorry Evan I got kidnapped
it's crazy crazy right I need I need you
know some personal time I mean I'm home
now I'm safe I was held for ransom
um yeah just
crazy but in that period like where is
he I'm sending messages back and forth
nothing happened and then um I found
Christina my my current editor now who's
been with me for I don't know how many
years many many years and then we hired
her husband
um then I hired a researcher so that we
can again like slowly niching down what
do I want to be great at I I love doing
the research on the videos
but I love being in front of the camera
more and spreading the message more so
then I hired somebody to help me do the
research uh so you slowly take away the
pieces of what you don't like doing or
don't want to be the world's greatest at
so you can focus on what you could be
does that make sense
all right thank you all right good
excellent question myself Fonda why dude
I didn't even recognize you with that
hat on fun the light in the house I love
it dude that smile
but I was just wondering about you
YouTube and I know you always said you
know create content every day but I'm
actually my YouTube channel in my videos
I'm actually doing the editing and
everything myself so it's not difficult
to do it every day but I guess there's
ways to I guess do it every day when
you're doing everything you know don't
add it yeah no sir like for for your
Ambitions like Fonda wants to be a
speaker
so the skill so if you're making a video
how long does it take you to a typical
video how long does it take you to
record it versus edit it and do all the
other stuff with it
recorded not not so long but editing
probably about 30 40 minutes and how
long to record it
uh I do little Clips so each clip is
about my videos are no longer than
six seven minutes
so if you're spending more time editing
than recording you're spending all your
time
training the wrong skill right yeah yeah
you want to be spending more time
speaking you're trying to train yourself
to be a great speaker this is just
imagine every time you pull out your
phone or whatever you're using to
record that you're on you're on some
stage
that's the skill you need to develop so
if I'm you I would do zero editing
okay to train yourself that from the
second you press record that it's like
you're on stage because when you're on
stage you don't get editing there's no
editing yeah so it's a good skill to
practice like if you if you if you only
train yourself that I can only be a good
speaker and deliver a message when it's
been cut up and edited
you're never going to be great on stage
right so treat every video like a stage
work whether you're whether you're in
your room there whether you're walking
outside you know whatever I still make
videos from my phone in my car for
myself Nina's going to Costco great
film
start recording rise and shine it's in
special time let's go
let's go uh yeah zero editing
okay because what's going to get you to
the point where you can then hire an
editor
um it's not going to be you producing a
video every couple days with your kind
of crappy editing right yeah and I'm I'm
not trying to insult you just no no I
get it be honest right like you know you
don't want to be a great editor so the
thing that will get you to the spot
where you can hire an editor is the
speaking because that's what you want to
be great at right so if you're anybody
here who wants to be a speaker you need
to be putting up daily videos practicing
you speaking Erasmus got his hand up and
a thumbs up like every day I need to see
you speaking because you'll get
discovered through those videos that
then you get paid to go do speaking gigs
but then you use that money to hire a
team to now help you edit the videos so
that they're crisper
but okay no editing is going to save you
if your speaking sucks right
and if you're speaking as fire it
doesn't matter what kind of editing is
on it right yeah
it's like nobody's tuning out because oh
my God this guy doesn't have lower
thirds on his on his video are you
kidding me if I'm out
right it's like can you speak to their
soul that's all that matters
yeah so zero editing I just I've just
given you more than double your time now
to actually go and make videos
okay thank you thank you cool man
hi Ivan this is iPhone here sorry I'm
not camera red it's iPhone hello from
iPhone I'm being fun
so I'm I'm an International Nurse and I
would like to write a book to write my
stories uh to what extent I should like
uh reveal my story at the other
technical
um part of my nursing experience what is
the perfect balance and mixed to relate
with my audience so if you if you go
through the thought leadership template
in here you'll see that story is super
important it's not the whole thing like
it shouldn't be half your story if
you're not writing a biography but the
story has to be at the beginning as a
setup
because before they're willing and this
is forever you know fond of making
videos at all of you if you're making
any kind of content I have to know your
story and where you come from before I'm
willing to listen to your advice so you
might be able to say hey here's how you
do XYZ which is what all of us just want
to teach
that's in our hearts like you want to
teach you want to help you know you have
knowledge that can serve people you just
want to tell them one two three go do it
the problem is people don't do it
they don't do it because you didn't
connect with them emotionally first
they have to know that you understand
them because when you give the advice
they just say Okay easy for that person
easy for you to say you don't understand
me right back to the very top when I was
talking about Evan tinsman so the
beginning is is the story so that I know
who you are where you come from that
you're exactly like me and then you
achieved and then the rest is going to
be the tips the advice that the tactics
the strategies of how to actually win
okay
Daniel's putting them on a new hat
hustle first all right hustle hustle or
hustle out what does that say hustle
hustle first all right I got it
yeah Evan Just In following with that
idea
um
would you suggest putting your stories
out of a series of YouTube things like
if they were two in four minutes long uh
putting your content into a story over
two or three videos or do it all at once
if you have a sequence that you're going
to put out in an email for example or on
your website for example then that can
make sense but when people are just on
YouTube they don't consume videos
sequentially right okay if you look at
my videos you haven't watched all my
videos in order
yeah I mean there's like six or seven
thousand public ones so it might be
scary if you've watched all of those we
have little competition like who's
watched them I want to see your watch
History who's watched the most videos
from the channel
um yeah first up like a two to four
Evanston is already claiming himself to
be the winner
um a two to four minute video is never
going to do well on YouTube period but
if if you're if you're embedding it on
your website if you're putting it as
part of your email sequence of people
who want to learn about you that can
work the story bit again I would follow
the model in build the serve you're
trying to teach but inside your argument
is a story that relates to it right and
you've got you've got ton all of you
have tons of stories that you could
share it's picking V1 right story for
this piece of content that you're about
to talk about so if I'm going to talk
about YouTube I have a story if I'm
going to talk about belief I have a
different story right right same thing
for me I have millions of different
stories just finding the one right story
but you wrap it inside of the theme and
the content and given advice at the end
not just your story and then hoping that
they watch your sequence yeah yeah
because I like that idea of having a
hook at the end of it just kind of say
bring them in okay so now you heard me
um you know how can I help you with that
kind of thing you know I want to be
there for you
yeah
Evan raised a finger
I was actually just going to share that
that um
I I just put something out the other day
I don't I don't edit anything I just
talk
um but that's what I actually I had a
talk with that family yesterday I had
mentioned to you that they're actually
flying me to Florida to help with
someone and they're paying me to do it
all expenses from just a little couple
minute that they followed me with my
journey but
from that somebody else had chimed in
and that gave me the topic of the video
that I just did a short one today and I
posted so if you share something of
whatever your personal story is and pay
attention to your comments people are
going to start asking because I did one
on addiction but then that turned into
hey Evan how do you handle like the
Stress and Anxiety that's what led me to
the one I'm doing now so people's
comments will pretty much tell you what
they want to hear
I love it and listen try to try to keep
the videos focused
and every piece of content focused
you have a lot of ID all of you have
lots of ideas lots of wisdom lots of
things to share but if you're all over
the place with the advice and the focus
if it's about addiction just keep this
one video on addiction you can make more
videos and other things afterwards it's
about having a powerful morning routine
then that's the video just keep it tight
and focused and then people will dive
into your world and want to learn more
about the other things that you're doing
but I love that I mean congrats that's
that's the power of like if Evan didn't
just release his video
and Fonda I know you got a client from
just your videos too on on Instagram
like somebody
you DM them and they they hired you and
what for six months I hired you now to
coach them yeah three months three
months three months like that's amazing
I love it like you guys are getting
business by just putting videos up on
the internet right but you know Evan
didn't release that video because you
didn't have time to edit it today maybe
he doesn't get that deal where now he's
being flown to Florida
right so they're not hiring Evan because
of his fancy editing and if you watch
his videos it's great he's either in his
chair there or he's in his car
and those are most of his videos and he
presses record and there's him talking
that that's that's what I want for all
of you guys to just release the burden
just make sure there's some kind of
light on your face right I mean go to
the window and have something in front
of you make sure you're not in the
middle of a windstorm or something
um super basic stuff but but you've got
you've got everything you need right
here on your phone press record and go
because you not producing a video a day
might have already cost you 10 clients
because you're worried about the editing
and that's not a Fonda thing that's a
everybody here thing
Raymond's done eating we like it welcome
there he's got erasmine you got a
question are you just waving High he's
got a question okay what do you got
yeah uh so Evan when you say that you
want to see us like speaking every day
um for us that want to be speakers like
how long do you think the content should
be or it just doesn't matter you ask you
go you get comfortable and it will get
longer or I want you to practice 10
minutes plus 10 minutes plus 10 minutes
plus okay if you can go deeper and go
longer with it great if you follow the
template here this it's a little hard to
follow the template by heart uh
as you go through it yeah I know I know
I know you got the book I know
um but at the end like the thought
leadership template
it's hard to remember everything right
it's hard to admit powerful opinion
context sentence racist Stakes tell a
story three bits of advice
what do I I'm just nervous to press
record in front of the camera
right so at the beginning just just
think about the getting that that hook
at the beginning like what's your
powerful opinion
and then once you practice that like if
you if you're doing the 100 video
challenge just once once you get that
down then the three sentences into a
story
and then after the story then you
practice given your opinion advice if
you follow that template you'll have a
10 minute plus video easy
okay there it is okay Daniel's Daniel's
holding up screenshots I like it thank
you yeah 10 minutes plus because it's
great practice for YouTube
um but for every video if you just
narrow down to powerful opinion story
and advice if you're like at the very
beginning just think about those three
things I'm leading with an opinion I'm
going to share some kind of story and
I'm going to give advice
right
so if if Evan was going to tell the
story about flying to Florida what's the
opinion at the top of that the Florida
story is the story and then he's going
to give advice
you know opinion story advice and as you
as you get more comfortable with that
then you can work out some of the
nuances that we outline in the book
okay thank you another Colorado get
another call all right Raymond what do
you got thank you
hey what's up everybody sorry I was
eating I didn't eat breakfast I've been
on calls all morning
um
something interesting if you don't mind
if I could share I just recently learned
and I haven't been doing my YouTube
videos I had to let go of my editor
because we didn't see eye to eye and he
wasn't in alignment with what I was
doing
um there's certain things that I learned
like I asked him to take notes on three
different occasions and he didn't and
then he did the things wrong and I said
listen I've asked you three times I
think we're done I tried to do it in the
Oreo cookie where it's like with a
comment and then you know uh praise and
then
you know with what's wrong but
anyway I've been on upwork and I've been
interviewing editors okay working to
build relationships so I could do this
sorry
um on my podcast
and also one thing I learned I forgot I
think it was from Jenna Kutcher that she
said when you do a video keep sharing
like I've been sharing it on LinkedIn
like every three days and because they
say six percent of people actually see
your videos and so I did this and I know
there's squirrel feeding all kinds of
things but I noticed just from doing
that if it's a good decent video my
second podcast is okay but um I kept
doing it and I just noticed I would get
more views and more comments and people
say dude cool wow you know like you know
engaging in the weird ways that we do
you know that's it what's the main
message of your channel Raymond oh the
main message for the podcast you're just
working with with people inspiring
inspiring us become the best versions of
our stuff and learning from setbacks
failures and gaining feedback okay great
so here here's the thing when's the last
time you posted a video on YouTube uh a
couple days ago so the whole Fallout
with you already editor was recent then
yes yeah well he did it like he edited a
week ago and then I was doing the
YouTube stuff you know making sure it
was aligned you know helping great
people you know to make sure I had the
right information but yeah it was recent
so so I would say it's I mean it sucks
but that's part of business you know it
means honestly it's probably in the
first you probably already knew a little
bit about that at the beginning and you
were trying to make it right but it
wasn't efficient you know so so better
on your next hire it's fine and you lead
with the mission
um
what's your one word what's your who
Freedom right it's like Freedom you lead
your upwork posting talking about
Freedom how you're trying to create
freedom for yourself and freedom for the
people who watch your content and how
you wanna you wanna build a a mindset of
freedom in this company so somebody who
wants to have freedom themselves you
know that's who you want to bring on so
you're going to start attracting the
right people
but you can't let this be a reason for
you not to post content
right so you have to post to YouTube
because if your message is how to bounce
back after setbacks you gotta demo it
what are you doing you're not posting
videos you're in a setback yeah the
video was hey guys it's raining this
looks not like my usual video but I've I
have a setback because somebody on my
team left but I don't want this to
Define me and not have my videos go up
so I'm if if I lost my whole team
I'm making videos dude
and and I was using this as an excuse
kind of like my message wasn't clear
compelling like uh
I wanted to script it so I'm hitting on
points but I was I believe I was letting
that get in the way
you know and it's not that you can't
work on a better script than in
improving but not at the expense of
videos not going up
understand thank you you got like finals
got to get his videos up does he have an
editor no so he's gonna do it himself or
just no editing get it up like videos
have to go up release the Perfection
yeah like like Evan even said just do
like a canva pick and then just do like
a
a video and then that's it and then just
keep doing that until you know we'll
throw into place I believe I believe
that's what happens tumbling blocks
turned into stepping stones but yeah 100
you can always go back later too as you
grow and fix all your old thumbnails and
titles and everything else but the thing
that will get you where you need to go
is you releasing content
so videos have to go up everything else
is secondary
so if you're giving it well I could do a
video I could do a video every day or I
could do a video every two days but have
it with a good title and a good
thumbnail and edited video every day
okay to start training that skill to get
better with that thing especially when
your messages had to bounce back after a
setback yeah you gotta demonstrate you
doing it you're in the middle of it I
gotta set back right now guys
and and whatever's going to your head of
like I'm worried that you're not gonna
like it I'm worried that it's not edited
well I'm worried that my messages are
concise without somebody cutting for me
but whatever I'm not gonna let this hold
me back do you talk about the setbacks
or no
yes yes okay that's recently
yeah like like dude did you watch me
make videos with my broken neck and like
giant scab on my face like every day I
made videos right concussion like not
even knowing what I was saying yeah no
right
I mean Evan saw me on that tour where he
saw me on the first day where I was fine
and then on the last day where I ended
up passing out on the floor afterwards
because it's just that insane trip that
I was on but I it was I broke my neck in
two spots and had a concussion and said
I was making videos every day and I
still even if it was for five minutes
would make a video
okay with like a huge scab like Giant on
my forehead sitting there in a in this
neck brace not even to be able to see
properly and like oversized Nike
pullover because I couldn't fit into
this thing propped up with like pillows
behind me and ice packs
dude but I'm so proud of that I still
keep my neck brace here on the on my
shelf I'm proud of
struggling through it is it my best
content hell no no that's not my best
content but like I did it
and for people who are going through the
Journey that's an inspiration as well
the people will see you and say wow look
he's doing it too
yeah because when somebody loses someone
on their team what are they gonna what
are you gonna say you say oh yeah I get
it I did the same thing I was like no so
you lose someone on your team you keep
going
here's what I did
yeah I mean I did I moved forward and
then I started putting out LinkedIn
intern ads so I am moving forward just
sometimes I know it's slower than
but you're right video every day it's
always slower than you want yeah like ah
you know always slower than you want
everything is always so you want it
yesterday do what I want I want
everything yesterday it's always slower
and you get up and you keep doing
something today yeah awesome thank you
so much
that's the best advice you could give us
for the week coming up I mean if my
volume is working why not like throw it
out there and give us something to I
don't know
just just uh you're right we have to
overcome struggles and poor struggle
into what we're doing and I know that's
how it works honestly the best advice is
like to
to get the content up whatever that
looks like for you not everybody has has
the Ambitions to go daily yet that might
sound crazy for some people here the
idea of making daily content but if
you're struggling to make one a week
then one a week no matter what you're
struggling to make three a week then
three a week you're starting to make
daily than daily no matter what like
even just show yourself for a week
you film yourself there in your living
room making content even though normally
you'd be somewhere else with the
lighting set up and whatever like just
don't give yourself the out of I'm Gonna
Keep tweaking and keep making it perfect
having a deadline like we keep trying to
make our videos better intros music uh
sources all of it always trying to hack
it to make it better and there's no way
that a video is not going up today
so when you start with that as the basis
like a video has to go up today period
or if that's a post or if it's an email
or whatever that equivalent looks like
in your world for everybody here it has
to go up it has to go up
and then inside what's my best effort
and maybe your best effort is just you
and your room doing it maybe your best
effort means you can throw a little bit
of graphics on it maybe maybe you're
dead tired and you had a crazy day but
your best effort is you lying in bed
saying guys
I suck I'm so tired right now but I had
to make a video
posts right and that's your video like
legit that is your video and you post
just to get it up
and build that muscle
guys thank you for the love amazing
super fun I have to pop uh Zan and I are
on tonight if you want to join in 6 p.m
Eastern on the channel
um yeah we'll be back again next week
I'll I love I love doing this I love
hanging out with you guys it's it's fun
to see repeat faces and also fun to see
some new faces if you're on next week uh
bring your questions again I want to see
you get your message out there to the
world because you got you got goodness
in here but it can't just stay here it's
got to get out there and we gotta
overcome our fears and overcome
rejection and overcome all of our
insecurities that you get that out there
so we can start actually have an impact
on the world I love you have a fantastic
end of the week and we'll see you next
week much love goodbye everybody we love
you
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there I'll see you there
I'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love